we can't wait to share our next chapter
with you the Duggar family is about to
get even bigger Jessa and her husband
Ben Seewald revealed that they're
expecting their third child together in
a statement posted to their website
Jessa says the baby is due this spring
though they aren't sure if they're
having a boy or a girl
quote from the day we found out we were
expecting we both guessed boy and if our
predictions are right then we already
have a ton of clothing and accessories
ready to pass down at the same time we
would absolutely love it if we found out
we were having a girl
Jessa and Ben are already parents to two
boys three year old Spurgeon and Henry
who is almost two on their site been
revealed their oldest son is already
talking about the new sibling quite a
bit adding quotes we love being parents
and are really looking forward to this
new arrival Ben is back at work now
mornings now with two kids I try to
sleep until Spurgeon wakes up and then
get up and our day starts from there
Jessa and sister Jill still star on
their TLC show counting on where their
family life is heavily documented she's
opened up about balancing family in the
past I kind of expect it to be a
challenge going from one to two kids I
feel like every day is different
somedays it's very very simple I'll just
you know change to diapers one right
after the other NAT the babies at the
same time and things go smoothly other
days it's a little more chaotic
[Music]